a new report looks at how long small
businesses anticipate these economic
obstacles in addition to what they are
now offering their employees to keep
them
cabbage from American Express pulled 550
Small Business Leaders and the latest
small business recovery report shows
businesses have nearly doubled Revenue
year over year between July of last year
and July of this year but profits did
not follow suit inflation is making a
meaningful dent in their business and so
from that same period they saw
tremendous Revenue growth but their
profits had slightly declined they
actually declined four percent during
that time period Brett Sussman says
these businesses anticipate future
economic obstacles to last at least
until summer of 2023 almost half the
businesses reported that inflation is
impacting their labor market they're
accommodating and compensating for
higher Health Care better employee
benefits and more frequent pay raises
they're in giving raises to their
existing employees in fact 40 percent
said they're looking to increase wages
on existing employees they're actually
providing more workplace flexibility
which you usually really think about for
larger companies and not smaller
companies so 49 said they're putting
practices in place that gives you
flexibilities when analyzing hybrid and
remote working options by business size
and age businesses less than two years
old are more likely to offer this to its
employees and these options are nearly
twice as likely to be implemented among
the largest small businesses compared to
the smallest small businesses Sussman
says it's a great tactic to retain
people and keep costs down
he also adds that small businesses have
to incorporate digital Facebook is
reported as the top platform nearly
doubled out of Instagram followed by
YouTube LinkedIn and Twitter